admitted sex abuser and accused sex
trafficker Jeffrey Epstein was found
injured and nearly unconscious in his
jail cell yesterday in what many friends
of Bill Clinton are calling a clear case
of attempted suicide we will examine
what is really going on in this sordid
saga then Ilhan Omar says more terrible
things the media meltdown on Bob
Muller's Week testimony on Capitol Hill
and finally the mail bag all that and
more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
of course Jeffrey Epstein was found
injured in his jail cell of course he
was now there are many theories flying
around about this I would never engage
in the notion that the Clintons have
obviously killed people I would know we
will we will analyse joking and sort of
joking aside we will analyze what is
most likely going on here and what this
injury is all about but first we have to
say a quick thank you to our friends
over at Quicken Loans who provide
support for the Michael Knowles show
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans your
home is so much more than a house it is
a little slice of heaven and that's why
when you find the perfect place getting
a mortgage shouldn't get in the way I
live in Los Angeles you know how
impossible it is to find a good house
there but the you know you go around all
these neighborhoods every has a 7
zillion dollars and compounding this
trouble is that in our generation nobody
knows how to do anything practical like
deal with mortgage companies and get a
loan fortunately rocket mortgage by
Quicken Loans is there to help their
team of mortgage experts is obsessed
with finding a better way which means
that their number one goal is to make
the home buying process smoother for you
they have industry-leading
online lending technology developed in
the heart of Detroit they are absolutely
changing the game they make the home
buying process work for you they're
there with award-winning client service
and support every step of the way for
most people buying a home is going to be
the biggest investment they ever make in
their lives don't screw it up and don't
leave yourself out there to be taken in
by a lot of complicated processes and
people with bad motives use the best
Quicken Loans has helped millions of
Americans achieve their dream of
homeownership and when you're ready to
purchase the home of your dreams they
can help you to their team cares about
getting you home they are ranked the
highest and customer satisfaction for
primary mortgage origination 9 years in
a row and highest in mortgage servicing
five years in a row you don't need to
just take my word for it they are
repeatedly being shown to be the best in
the game when you work with them you get
more than just a loan because rocket
mortgage is much more than just a lender
visit rocket mortgage.com / Knowles ko
wles do it right now take the first step
toward the home of your
rheems Equal Housing lender licensed in
all 50 states nmls consumer access organ
number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage just that simple
Jeffrey Epstein admitted sex abuser of
young underage girls accused sex
trafficker of young underage girls has
lots of very rich and wealthy and
powerful friends all over the world and
he winds up injured at the point of
death in his jail cell so what is going
on here is it the case that Bill
Clinton's hit man didn't finish the job
or is there something else going on I'm
kidding I'm mostly I'm mostly kidding
let's look at the facts first and then
we can examine the three possibilities
of what's going on here Jeffrey Epstein
he's not being held in the private wing
of the Palm Beach County Jail anymore
like he was 10 years ago he is being
held in a real tough place the
Metropolitan Correctional Center in New
York for comparison this is the place El
Chapo was held this is no joke this
place has been described by people who
have been there as worse than Guantanamo
this is a real real tough place a 2011
report from Amnesty International said
that conditions in the Metropolitan
Correctional Center or in in particular
the ten south wing of that Correctional
Center amounted to quote cruel inhumane
or degrading treatment that was quote
incompatible with the presumption of
innocence in the case of untried
prisoners whose detention should not be
a form of punishment so this is a
hardcore facility he also was housed
with somebody named Nicolas Tarte Alyona
Nicolas Tortelli own a with a name like
that you might think he could be
associated with a particularly criminal
aspect of the italian-american
subculture but no he actually is a
former cop he's a former cop who became
a dirty cop he got involved in drugs and
drug trafficking and ended up killing
people so he is there too there are
three possibilities I guess really four
possibilities here one is the Jeffrey
Epstein actually attempted suicide I
mean this guy is facing
what will amount to life in prison and
not at pleasant time in prison so he
could have actually attempted suicide
himself or he could have faked a suicide
attempt in order to get himself
transferred to a better Jail
since he's in basically the worst one
you can possibly be in right now
or one of the very powerful people one
of the many most powerful and richest
and connected people in the world that
he is associated with who he could
possibly bring down because he has dirt
and blackmail on all of them would very
much like it if he winds up dead and
then the fourth possibility is that this
guy that he was in the jail with
Nicholas Tortelli ohne was the one who
tried to kill him I think this last one
is the least plausible it's not like
we're talking about him being housed
with some white supremacist gang member
who's trying to make a name for himself
or something he's being held in a
private wing particularly and
specifically to combat those threats
he's already had threats on his life
from people in the general prison
population so the idea that some ex-cop
who's also being held basically on his
own is going to be the one to off him I
just think that's not very likely and
the people who are familiar with the
situation are saying that the cop and
Epstein basically got along and we're
doing fine together so I don't think
it's that one I think it's one of the
three an actual suicide attempt a fake
suicide attempt or one of his powerful
friends former friends trying to shut
him up before he can expose their crimes
now this last one is the one that's
trending on Twitter right now the
Clinton body bag count you know there's
been this meme that's going around for
25 years now that the Clintons kill a
lot of people because all of these
people that have been associated with
the Clintons wind up dead not just Vince
Foster who worked for the White House
very famously in the 90s but of a lot of
other people too now if you look at any
one of these deaths on the Clinton
body-count list it just doesn't seem
likely that they killed him the
cumulative effect is sort of compelling
to people as far as memes on the
internet go I'm not saying that the
Clintons have killed people that's not
what I'm saying at all what I'm saying
is the reason that this meme this
has made it this far and has lasted for
25 years is because we all know that the
Clintons totally would kill people right
we all know that these are absolutely
thoroughly dishonest corrupt psychopaths
to the core I mean the Clintons lie like
it's the air I mean there's no they have
no regard for the truth they have no
regard for loyalty and they are vicious
psychopathic people so the reason the
meme has lasted is because we all we all
know that they would do it now that
doesn't mean they did do it and I don't
think they did it what I it is certainly
possible though that many of the other
very wealthy and connected people that
they're that Jeffrey Epstein is
associated with might try to do that as
well I mean let's not forget the
Southern District of New York found a
Saudi passport in his safe a Saudi
passport from the 80s with a different
name on it but with his picture what
does that mean
we can I think assume at this point that
Epstein is pretty high level sex
trafficker was he may be providing some
favors for people in Saudi Arabia
well how about all of the other
high-powered people around the world
that he's he's piled around with over
the decades it's not implausible at all
that someone would try to knock knock
him off now though the one reason that I
think this is not likely in this case is
because he's being held at a very
serious place El Chapo wasn't able to
break out of this place I'm not
convinced that someone could very easily
go in and off Jeffrey Epstein at this
metropolitan correction facility so
let's for now table that idea that
someone's trying to kill him plenty of
people have motives too plenty people
would do it I just don't think that's
likely here number two did Epstein
actually attempt suicide Jeffrey Epstein
is a completely shameless individual
right he has flaunted his sexual
proclivities and his sexual businesses
for twenty years now he has an island
that people called pedophile island
private island he has a plane that
people called the Lolita Express you
know in profiles of Jeffrey Epstein
people joked about how President Trump
joked about how he was always around
those younger
women he really liked younger women this
is a guy with no shame whatsoever
he's already copped to sex with underage
girls ten years ago more than ten years
ago
and he continues to do it even to this
day I don't think he has any remorse any
regret any shame at all I think it's
very unlikely that he would try to kill
himself which brings us to the third
possibility which we'll get to in one
second but first I have got to say thank
you to my friends over at zip recruiters
zipped recruiter is the only way to hire
people
zip recruiter is the only way to get
hired zip recruiter sends your job out
to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards but they don't just stop there
that's what everybody does that's just
okay they send the job out and that's it
it's like throwing spaghetti at the wall
what zip recruiter does though the
reason they're the best in the game is
because of their powerful matching
technology so zip recruiter will scan
thousands of resumes or more and find
people with the right experience and
invite them to apply to your job so
you're not just throwing spaghetti at
the wall zipper cruder is actively going
out there finding you the right
candidate then once they do that is the
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you will never miss a
great match zip recruiter is so
effective it is so out of the league
compared to all the other guys that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a qualified candidate
through the site in just one day
so right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address and you have to go to this one
pull over stop what you're doing go to
zip recruiter dot-com slash Knolls KO
wles the zip recruiter dot-com slash
Knowles you know we we hire people all
the time and it's it can be very
difficult to get quality candidates time
is money
guys don't waste your time don't waste
your resources just go for it zip
recruiter is the way to get quality
candidates I can't even think of a
second place this is the way to do it
zip recruiter comm slash Knowles canna
wles zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire so I think all things considered no
matter how depraved the Clintons are no
matter how much
ouch and power all of his other foreign
friends have former friends I think it's
unlikely that someone tried to kill
Epstein here I also think it's unlikely
that he tried to kill himself what I
think is actually going on is that he
faked a suicide attempt I think he faked
a suicide attempt because all Jeffrey
Epstein wants is to get out of this jail
what he really wants is to get out on
bail he made this exorbitant absurd
offer to get out of jail on on bail the
trouble is once he gets out on bail he's
gonna flee the country right there's no
chance that this guy is sticking around
he's got his own Island for goodness
sake he is a Bond villain so the judge
rightly was not going to let this guy
out on bail next best case would be to
get out of this awful El Chapo prison
facility and go to a nicer prison and if
that means that he's got to pretend to
hang himself or something or choke
himself for a little bit I think it's
it's likely that he would do that he was
taken to the hospital apparently the
injuries were not that serious if this
were a hardcore suicide attempt first of
all it probably would have worked and
and also would it would have resulted in
more serious injuries by the way this is
another reason why I don't think it was
a hit man you know I don't think it was
the black gloved assassins of the
Clintons or somebody like that is if it
were the black loved assassins of the
Clintons Jeffrey Epstein would be dead
he wouldn't be around to tell the story
so I don't think it's that I think it's
a cynical ploy to get out of jail and to
to either get out on bail or go to a
place that isn't so horrific I mean this
is a very high-level guy Jeffrey Epstein
this is a top-tier operator in politics
and Finance and crime and I wouldn't put
anything past him so I hope that he
stays rotting in that facility and I
hope they keep him on protection I mean
I hope they continue to protect this guy
because in fact there are a lot of
powerful people in this country and
around the world who would like nothing
more than for Jeffrey Epstein to turn up
dead before he can sing on them speaking
of child abuse
speaking of child abuse about what was
it three days ago I think on Monday we
talked about this guy Jessica yaniv a
man and a dress
sauntered into a Canada beauty salon
it's run by immigrant women and they do
Brazilian waxes for women and he
insisted that they wax his scrotum and
and they said no and now he sued them
out of business and he's done this to 16
other beauty salons and everyone is
trying of people on the left at least
are trying to portray him as a victim
drinks oh he's a transgender woman
transgender women are women that's what
we're told and it's it's awful that he's
getting this kind of treatment turns out
as I could have predicted this man is a
sexual predator who could have guessed
could you imagine it's now come out that
this man his name is Jessica Yan Eve I
don't know what his name was before he
turned it into Jessica he was sending
very charged sex sexual messages to a
fourteen-year-old girl when he was 27
years old
yaniv was in these text messages which
have now been leaked by the girl
yaniv lines that the girl is not yet
sixteen and therefore because of age of
consent laws he cannot quote do anything
with you like for use in there in other
messages yaniv closure is if you don't
wanna hear something truly disgusting in
other messages you need asked to see the
girls menstrual pad 14 years old he was
a 27 year old man still is a man but
back then he was acknowledging that he
was a man then in another instance he
sent a voice message in an Elmo voice a
muppet voice and he was singing Jessica
rumple's that's a girl's name breasts
bounce up and down in the little
childish Elmo voice he also told Rumple
that he was horny and he followed it up
by telling the girl why are you always
so beautiful lol and then he sent her a
video of a sex toy this guy Jessica Univ
is the villain from season 1 of another
Kingdom if you haven't seen another
Kingdom that's the podcast that I did
with drew Clavin the the villain is this
kind of transvestite androgynous
criminal hitman figure who speaks in a
lilting
Eydie voice this this guy is him this
guy is the villain and it shows you the
reason I bring it up is not because of
what weirdo this guy is or how awful it
was that he ran those women at a
business up in Canada or how awful it
was that some people were defending him
I bring it up because it shows you what
just a little change of language can do
right this guy we knew nothing about
this guy all we knew about him is that
he wore a dress and put an immigrant
woman out of business and you had some
people defending him because he's an
oppressed victim we were told that this
is a woman what the left percent of this
guy has is as a transgender woman now a
woman is always a victim compared to a
man in the intersectional hierarchy of
victimhood and a transgender person is
always a victim compared to someone who
believes that he is the biological sex
that he is so he's a double victim he's
a he's a transgender woman in the
victimhood language in reality though
what is he he's a male predator he's not
a female victim he's a male predator
criminal just that little change of
language
beyond this guy Jessica Yaniv if you go
over to the stories we've been hearing
around the country of drag queens story
hour do you remember this all all around
the country for some reason at public
libraries they've had something called
drag queens story hour where little kids
are brought in to have stories read to
them by drag queens men wearing very
sort of sexualized
and sensational makeup and women's
outfits now they had a drag queen story
hour at an event in Portland and the
library is celebrating it they're
posting photos of it we were told those
of us who objected to drag queens story
hour we were told you're awful you're
bigots you're transphobic you're a
hateful person you're hate mongering
that big debate that broke out on the
right between so Rob Amari at first
things and David French at National
Review / cultural conservatism versus
libertarianism that debate was kicked
off by drag queen story out
so Rob Amore's piece said look when we
reach drag queens story our two children
we have gone too far we need to
re-examine some of our libertarian
premises and what so Rob and other
people were saying is this this amounts
to child abuse it's not maybe it's not
physically abusing children but it is so
confusing it is so utterly absurd the
ideology and the gender ideology that
you're indoctrinating these kids with we
should not do it all called haters for
that well guess what turns out that the
photos have now been deleted but the
library posted photos but apparently as
part of this drag queen story our in
Portland Oregon the drag queen who would
come in would lie down on the floor and
then encourage all of the kids to crawl
all over him what does that have to do
with reading a story in a public library
that's pretty weird just imagine for a
second if a straight man wearing a
business suit walked into a public
library said okay I'm gonna what I want
to do with my time is I want to come in
here once or twice a week and I want to
read books to a lot of like little
children I want the little children to
gather all around me and then I'm gonna
lie down on the ground in my business
suit and then I'm going to encourage the
kids to crawl all over my body
okay is that is that cool of course not
the guy would be arrested if he did that
but because the man puts on a dress and
makeup the pop culture the leftist
culture celebrates it takes photos of it
is so blind by their ideology that they
upload the photos to the Internet as
though this is perfectly normal and
worth celebrating it's insane that is
the effect of ideology that is the
effect of language because because if if
a woman let's say a young woman or a
mother or something came into the
library and she was kind of playing
around with the kids and their baby they
were on the floor you know and she was
reading the story to them and then I
don't know what kid jumps on her back or
something right because mothers are
nurturing because women are nurturing it
it would be a little weird but it
wouldn't be that weird it wouldn't be as
weird as if a straight male in his 50s
came in in a business suit and said hey
kids I'm gonna lie on the floor rub all
over me please but for some reason when
you say it's a it's a man wearing a
dress it looks like a woman who's
transgender when you had all of these
different layers of apparent victimhood
to it then it's to be celebrated then
we're going to post pictures of that
what it shows is the currency of
victimhood in Texas it's not just this
one drag queen story hour in Portland in
Texas when people objected to drag queen
story our same thing or you're a bigot
you're a transphobia hater
turns out one of the one of the guys who
was coming in to do this drag queen
story hour was a convicted sexual
predator he was a sex offender maybe
they should have checked that but
they're so blinded by their ideology
because of the language and because of
the currency of victimhood if you can
claim victimhood in 2019 you can do
anything you can do anything you want
and this we're talking a little bit
yesterday about how the left abandons
their pet victim groups when something
better comes along
so they abandon legal immigrants for
illegal immigrants right initially they
were they were the champions of legal
immigrants now they're the champions of
illegal immigrants but legal immigrants
don't tend to encourage illegal
immigration they're in fact legal
immigrants are some of the least likely
people to encourage illegal immigration
because legal immigrants did it the
right way and they waited in line and
illegal immigration takes pots away from
people who are waiting there in line to
be legal immigrants the left abandons
women for men in dresses remember the
left used to champion women's rights
feminism women's liberation now what the
left is doing is saying hey women you
can't have your own sports women you
can't have your own scholarships women
you can't have your own bathrooms or
your own locker rooms is now we've
champion men in dresses
now the left is abandoning children for
men in dresses think of the children
think of the children remember that now
the left is saying no no children crawl
all over that man yeah let that man lie
on the ground and you can crawl all over
him they will do whatever gives them the
most control and the reason this
transgender issue
I mean we've talked about what the
pronouns mean the effect of the language
but think about what the effect of the
language is over time the reason that
the left is so interested in this
transgender issue is it gives them the
most control because it cuts right
through the politics in the culture to
who can define reality itself this
transgender issue is not a mere
political issue it is about ontological
control it is about who can define the
nature of reality compared to that
illegal immigration is nothing
what is he illegal immigration do let's
say we bring in we've got out let's say
we have upwards of 30 million illegal
aliens in the country we have an amnesty
illegal aliens keep pouring in let's say
we have thirty million well if the vast
majority of them are likely to identify
as Democrats and vote Democrat over time
okay that gives Democrats political
control they'll own the Congress they'll
own federal elections and they'll own a
few states but the transgender issue
doesn't just give them political control
it allows them to define what is
contrary to nature itself that is an
incredible amount of control that's why
they're willing to put up with just
about anything they're willing to
tolerate even encourage anything in
order to affect that speaking of radical
awful leftists we have to turn for a
second to Ilhan omar who has said
another terrible thing now if we covered
every terrible thing she said the whole
show the whole show would be called
Michael Knowles plays clips of Ilhan
Omar because we would have about ten of
them every single day but here is one
that is so outrageous and it's getting a
lot of play on social media because
people are defending her and we just
need to break down how absurd it is here
is Ilhan Omar she was asked by a
constituent if she would condemn female
genital mutilation which is something
that's widely practiced practiced in
Muslim countries and in her own home
country of Somalia here is her response
question is an appalling question
because I always feel like there are
bills that we vote on bills we sponsor
many statements we put out and then
we're in in a panel like this and the
question is posed could you appreciate
it do this and I'd say how often should
I make a schedule like does this need to
be on repeat every five minutes should I
be like so today I forgot to condemn al
Qaeda so here's the ok the one today
[Applause]
it's a very frustrating question well
it's pretty frustrating that you won't
give an answer it's not like this is
coming out of the blue it's not like
people are are asking Ilhan Omar every
single day to condemn al Qaeda and she
keeps doing it every day I mean compare
this to President Trump how many
hundreds of times as president Trump
condemned racism condemn the KKK condemn
David Duke condemned and neo-nazism
condemned white nationalism seems like
he has to do it every three minutes but
he keeps doing it and after the
hundredth time he says guys how much do
I have to do it and he keeps doing it
anyway when his Ilhan Omar condemned al
Qaeda Ilhan Omar giggled about Al Qaeda
giggled about Hamas giggled this is all
on video giggled as she compared al
Qaeda to the United States compared al
Qaeda to the US Army compared al Qaeda
to England drew a moral equivalence
between the United States itself and
Muslim terrorists she has fought hard to
get lenient sentences for a young men
who have tried to join Isis
she has prayed that Allah awakened
people to the evils of Israel and
accused Israel of hypnotizing the world
she has said some pretty radical things
that pertain to radical Islam and
Islamic countries in her home country of
Somalia 98% of women and girls are
subjected to female genital mutilation
and this is
become a problem over in Minnesota now
it's true Ilhan omar voted once on a
non-binding resolution to condemn female
genital mutilation she also voted on an
amendment that would have allocated some
money to fighting this problem but when
you're constantly joking laughing about
Al Qaeda when you're not addressing
these issues it is not bigoted it's not
hateful it's not Islamophobic to come
out and say hey al honimaru you say a
lot of crazy weird scary anti-american
things we just want to be sure you
oppose this right and she just won't
give the answer she goes on issues that
other people are not so I want to make
sure that the next time someone is in an
audience and is looking at me and
Rashida and Abdul and Sam then they ask
us the proper questions
yes there is an assumption among a lot
of people in the country that Ilhan Omar
might have some sympathy for al Qaeda
but that's not an assumption based on
the color of her skin that's not an
assumption based on her religion it's
not an assumption based on what country
she was born in it's an assumption based
on her many statements that have shown
sympathy toward al Qaeda and other
radical Muslim terrorists it is an
assumption based on her actions which
have shown sympathy for radical Muslim
terrorists and I don't think it's
unreasonable to ask her to condemn them
like even just one time
imagine if Donald Trump were giving this
answer someone asked Trump like they
always ask him do you condemn racism and
he said I think this question is
appalling I think what guys like me and
Mike Pence and other white guys and his
name's a bunch of white guys we're being
asked because of the color of our skin
to condemn racism that's an outrageous
how many tought I'm never I'm not going
to give an answer to that and I don't
want anyone to ever ask me that again
there is a lot more evidence that Ilhan
Omar has sympathies for al Qaeda then
there is that Donald Trump is a racial
bigot
there is way more evidence but Ilhan
Omar gets to give that non answer she
gets to refuse to condemn al Qaeda and
female genital mutilation because she
gets to claim victimhood and president
Trump who has repeatedly done all of
those things gives no similar benefit of
the death that's the power of language
that's the power of the of the left
taking control not just of political or
even cultural issues but they are trying
to control the definition of reality
itself and they're doing it in a very
sophisticated and clever way they're
doing it by by taking control of what
reality is of what a man is of what a
woman is and the end through this
radical ideology of intersectionality
the only objective reality that you can
point to the only objective truth is the
truth of victimhood and coincidentally
they're the arbiters of that victimhood
it's a brilliant political strategy and
we've
to oppose it because it is
extraordinarily dangerous now we will
get to a lot of mailbag questions we
have to do that in a second but first I
have got to invite you come come on in
I'm in a hotel room right now in
Washington DC I'm going to be giving a
talk at the young America's Foundation
on next Tuesday but if you're not in DC
if you're not checking out yeah if you
have to come to our backstage live show
we're going on the road special
one-night only event August 21st we're
not going to be doing more events like
this this year this is the one time at
the incredible terrorist theater in Long
Beach California ben shapiro daily wire
god-king jeremy boring andrew Clavin and
me we will all be chopping up the
winners and losers at politics and pop
culture best of all we'll be answering
your questions from the audience alive
so make those questions good tickets are
available at daily wired.com slash
backstage there are still a few VIP
ticket packages available I've actually
seen people I'm at EP USA right now and
I've seen people that I met at our last
event that we did for the Daily wire
which was about this time last year
these are great opportunities we all
love talking to you guys and we think
it's fun for the audience as well so
just come on out it's going to be a
great time the VIP packages have premium
seating photos and meet and greets with
all of us a gift from Shapiro and so
much more
head to Daly wire.com slash backstage
get your tickets today go over to Daly
wire.com slash backstage do it pick up a
leftist ears tumbler while you're at it
we'll be right back with the mailbag
all right we're gonna burn through these
questions today from Matthew Michael ex
lothario of The Daily wire
I'm an excellent Aria what happened
about that maybe because I'm married I
sent you a question a few weeks ago
about when to kiss a girl I'd been on a
few dates with I kissed her on the next
date good job and she held my hand good
job two days later she tells me she's
not ready for a serious relationship
but this upsets her because I'm this
perfect guy hundred percent a gentleman
and I'd managed to sweep her off her
feet
apparently even sweep her too much sorry
to say I think we saw she saw a future
with me saw that it was different than
what she had in mind and panicked I'd
like another shot at her but I'm not
sure how to go about it
given the circumstances any advice you
can give on this front would be
appreciated hashtag came for Ben stayed
for Michael happy feast of Saint James
and keep up the good work
Thanks yours met very difficult position
you are in my friend so a couple options
there real I guess there were only two
things that could be going on right here
one you really did sweep her off her
feet she really does think you're a
great guy she really sees a serious
prospect with you but she's just doing
her now she doesn't want a serious
relationship she's focusing on her job
or on school or she's gonna move or I
don't know where she's still got a thing
for her ex-boyfriend I don't know that's
that's one option is she could be
telling the truth
the other one is she could be being nice
to you and kind of letting you down
gently but you know and basically
perfect i 100% of gentleman all of that
is bogus either way I don't think it
matters which it is to determine your
reaction here if you really like the
girl and you you want to persist a
little bit then I would recommend it you
know i-i've had to be persistent and I
think women reward persistence they
don't want some little timid guy who she
says I don't want to go on a date like
okay I'm sorry no good never mind delete
my number alt and I'll never talk to you
again at that no one wants that however
you've got to be gentlemanly and you've
got to be a little crafty here too
so this this leads to another dichotomy
there are two ways that you can present
yourself to this girl
you can either present yourself as okay
reserved standoffish you're not that
interested you totally respect your
space and play hard-to-get and then
maybe she'll come to you maybe you came
on a little strong and she'll come back
to you the other way you can do it is be
very upfront about your interest you say
well look I think you're great I really
like you I think you're beautiful
and you're very interesting and
intelligent and so I want to go on a
date with you and you know I'm gonna be
at this restaurant on Friday night and I
sure would like you to join me and just
kind of be that way I'd keep it fun keep
it light don't make it creepy and don't
don't be you know a stalker or something
but let her know that you are still
interested and you're not that easily
deterred though I think those are the
two options the worst ground you could
be in is this a middle ground where
you're it's just like timid and unsure
and you're not sure if you're pursuing
her or you're not pursuing her or
whatever I think it's perfectly
legitimate to say well I mean look I
don't I don't think we need to I'm not
asking you to marry me I'm asking you to
go out on another date with me and you
know you're not making a lifetime
commitment I just thought we had a good
time and if you think that we had a good
time then let's do it
now she might tell you okay I was
letting I was letting you down easy I
didn't have a good time and I don't care
and I don't want to go out with you
anymore
in which case plenty other fish in the
sea kid but they're all it's also a
chance to say okay maybe I maybe I
really do like this guy and I'm afraid
of my feelings and okay I'll go out on
one more day that's how I would do it
I've always been pretty upfront pretty
direct and and I ended up getting to
marry my high school sweetheart
talk about persistence I mean that's
years and years of persistence so good
luck you know be confident keep it fun
keep it light don't be creepy don't be a
stalker don't be overly emotional don't
be you know don't do any of those modern
things that the guys fall into act like
a man go after what you want
and if she firmly rejects you of
deficiency from Martin hi Michael would
it be a good strategy by Trump's team to
now key playing small bits of
impeachment bait for the
Democrats to keep obsessing over till
2020 Martin yeah I think so I think all
the threats of impeachment really helped
Trump I think there are two good ways to
do this one is he wanted to add a
question to the census that would have
asked whether or not you're an American
citizen obviously this was perfectly
legitimate the Supreme Court didn't want
to let him do it because John Roberts is
a coward so I would if I were President
Trump I would issue an executive order
to put the question on the census and I
have this legal fight going on and I
would have the threats of impeachment
he's already signaled that he's not
willing to do that he signaled that back
on July 11th or 12th I think so I think
it that might be unlikely but it would
be a good way to gin up both popular
support for him and antipathy for him in
the house that might try to impeach him
and then therefore antipathy among the
American people for the House Democrats
the other way that he could do it is the
mass deportation of criminal aliens
which we were promised a week ago on
Sunday and it didn't happen and we only
arrested 18 people I think that would be
a great way to again do exactly the same
thing galvanized popular support among
Americans because Americans hate illegal
immigration immigration is the top issue
for Americans according to recent Gallup
polling and so you get a lot of popular
support and because the Democratic Party
has moved so far left nothing would get
them more ready to impeach than mass
deportation of ms-13 gangster criminals
and so you'd get them to move to impeach
and that would that would amplify the
effect of support for Trump so those are
the two things I would do whether
they're likely whether Trump is willing
to make that political risk I'm not so
sure from Logan hey Michael do you enjoy
these Sherlock Holmes stories I just
started reading them and really enjoy
them if so do you have a favorite story
and why god bless
hashtag came for been stayed for Michael
I do in fact I love the Sherlock Holmes
stories my favorite one is the adventure
of the musgrave ritual one of the
lesser-known
Sherlock Holmes stories I think and it's
excellent the reason I love it is it has
to do with one of my favorite historical
periods namely the reign of James the
second in England and Charles
second Charles to that whole area which
has to do with a lot of religious wars
and the last moments of the glory days
of the English monarchy so that's a good
one to read also what I like in addition
to Sherlock Holmes is the Father Brown
stories which is the same concept
instead of just a regular private
investigator it's a Catholic priest who
is a detective and he solves mysteries
and it was written by G K Chesterton one
of the great great modern writers great
writers in the 20th century and yeah or
19th century right around right around
that time the turn of the century and
it's just wonderful he's got all of
these stories and they're the same kind
of thing as Sherlock Holmes and the one
to start with is the innocence of Father
Brown from Cody hey Michael
my daughter is a high school senior this
year and interested in positively
affecting the culture however she has no
background in debate and gets terribly
nervous and tongue-tied
whenever she ends up engaging with some
whiny leftist what advice would you give
her for improving her skills in fact
memory and civil discourse thanks for
all you do Cody I'll give an answer that
probably no other political commentator
will give your daughter should take
acting classes that's the way to do it
I don't think debate class or the debate
team is gonna do it I don't think she
needs to read a million more books of
modern political philosophy I don't know
that that'll those are all fine to do
acting classes will do wonders for her
ability to debate leftists to understand
the world and to retain things that she
reads in a former life I was an actor
myself and that training I call upon
every single day President Reagan was
asked how an actor can be president and
his answer was how could the president
not be an actor and an in a very
technical way it teaches you how to
memorize you know there were many
different ways to memorize I mean I
could basically look at a sheet of paper
and memorize what it says with 95%
accuracy within about three to five
minutes but I'll forget it within two
hours now there are other ways to
memorize where I I have monologues
speeches things that
poems that I memorized 15 20 years ago
that I still remember today word
perfectly so you you will learn those
things in acting classes you will learn
to think on your feet acting is is
reacting to imaginary circumstances and
living truthfully in imaginary
circumstances so it makes you much more
adept at responding to questions that
you get from the audience or the points
made by another debater it makes you
have a greater stage presence it makes
you more self-possessed and it allows
you I think very importantly to analyze
the human condition from an artistic
perspective too often we want to make
our politicians into robots that's why
they end up like robots so they all they
do is think an ideology and this
political doctrine and that political
doctrine that doesn't tell you very much
about human nature it what tells you
much more about human nature is
literature art man is artistic all we
know about our earliest forebears the
cavemen we don't know whether they Club
their wives on the head we don't know
exactly what they ate we don't know
exactly how they hunted we don't know
exactly how they lived all we have from
their civilizations more or less or
paintings on the wall of the cave all we
know about them is that they were
artists and it is through art that we
can come to understand human nature much
better than we can through some
political doctrine so maybe sign her up
for an acting class maybe ever watch
some acting classes on YouTube have her
memorize poems have her read plays have
her memorize speeches have her really
work through all of that this is a real
difference between practical knowledge
and a book learning you know you can
only learn so much from books you have
to embody the rest of it you have to
enact the rest of it and what better way
to enact then in an acting class or an
acting setting last question from
Danielle hi Michael I'm curious about
your opinion of genetic screening the
idea of being able to spare a child's
life
pain pain and suffering by way of
genetic screening for disorders is
curious to me is this selfish for the
parent to want a healthy child
or is it selfless to make the decision
so a child isn't strapped with the
issues that come with that
excellent question I was just discussing
this yesterday I obviously
as I suspect you do too in the case of
screening for abortion so you you do
genetic screening and then there's they
find some problem with the baby and then
you kill the baby nobody wants to do
that that is just intrinsically evil
however if you are screening because you
can identify some disease and maybe
these days even operate on the baby in
the womb and cure the disease so that
they will have an easier life or they'll
have their sight or they'll have that
they'll have a physically healthier life
that's perfectly fine that's a wonderful
thing to do it's no different than
giving medical treatment to someone who
is out of the womb or someone who is
thirty years old or someone who is 70
years old it's a good thing to do that
this is not to say that people who are
born with physical deformities or
they're blind or they're deaf or
whatever or mental deficiencies are or
worse or they have less human dignity or
they no not at all actually the the fact
that everybody is broken and people have
needs is a wonderful gift to us because
we can then act out of charity and it
enriches our experience of humanity and
experience of one another it makes life
worth living but if you can help your
child whether your child's in the womb
or your child is ten years old
absolutely you should do it
there is nothing immoral about that okay
that's our show in the meantime I will
see you on Monday
till then I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show see that
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka watts and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show well yesterday's
mulher hearings expose the Russia hoax
for what it is and listen it's not that
I enjoyed seeing the Democrats and their
media humiliated oh wait
that's exactly what I enjoyed you'll be
able to hear me gloat shamelessly on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin